The bees play a fateful role on Earth, so that some of them claim that if extinct, it will be followed by humanity
_ Translation of AraSense _
So, with this massive drop in bee numbers, do we have to worry?
What happens if all bees die?
Simply put, if the plant produces a flower, you can bet that the bees will help them reproduce.
This effective, long-lasting relationship with the floral and floral flowers attracts bees
, And helps bees _ his body fluffy - like Velcro adhesive _ Pollen pollute efficiently
From the male part of the plant to the female part of it
This seemingly simple mechanism is directly responsible for producing 70% of the vegetables, fruits, seeds and nuts we consume on a daily basis.
70%! This translates to the equivalent of $ 200 billion of global agricultural income.
This huge responsibility is accomplished by groups of bee merchants raised by professional Nahlimin for a single purpose,
It is transferred to farms and orchards to be cleared by crops.
But since 2006, these energetic and active bees have mysteriously disappeared.
The chaos of the collapse of the colonies has left about a third of the commercial bees abandoned.
In fact, some beekeepers reported that 90% of their bees simply,
He came out and no longer
In some colonies, mites, viruses, parasites,
But now many take into consideration a class of insecticides called neonotinoid compounds.
This neurotic toxin is used to kill insects that feed on crops,
It also affects the central nervous system when bees absorb polluted nectar.
Since nectar is transferred to cells, the entire colony may be affected, leading to confusion and mismanagement.
On top of this, other factors such as long and cold winter seasons,
The lack of genetic diversity in commercial bees, and limited nectar in the fields, may be the cause.
If the situation continues, the entire food chains and networks may be at risk.
Take the plant for example;
These nuts are used as feed for chickens and farm animals.
Less bees mean fewer almonds, which may lead to fewer cattle, and ultimately fewer milk, cheese, eggs and meat production.
Not to mention that almonds are used in grain products, bread and many other food products.
Ordinary cows and milking cows may also be severely affected by the disappearance of alfalfa fields
Which are used to harvest hay for cattle.
Are you looking forward to activating in the morning?
As bees pollute Arabic coffee, which grinds its seeds for coffee, you should rule out that.
In the absence of bees, our diet will consist of the bulk of corn, wheat and rice,
As they are plants fertilized by wind.
Do you like your clothes? Not only is cotton the most lucrative crop in the United States,
But also represents about 35% of the world's used textile fibers.
If you can forget all the jeans, towels, towels and family brushes
And high quality paper products.
Simply put, we will live in a completely different world in the absence of bees,
This is without mentioning the suffering of great economic pressure because of his absence.
So, while we will not necessarily get extinct if this pattern continues to decline,
However, a world without the buzz of bees will undoubtedly be ... very painful.
Do you want a free copy of our new book? You can now get it from Audible.com/asap
Which is the leading provider of audio books with more than 150,000 titles available for download on all types of literature.
Our book appeared last week and covers a large amount of questions that have never been answered in our videos, and we're very excited to share it with you!
You can download or download any other audio book of your choice, free of charge on audible.com/asap
Special thanks to this website to make these videos available to everyone, thank you too
For your continued support for the presentation of our book and your support for scientific education,
That means a lot to us!
And if you missed the torrent of direct science last week, we played the periodic table song and answered your passionate questions!
Make sure you check it here, or use the link in the description below.
Subscribe to more weekly science videos!